how much thought goes into I'm putting
out thought into it I just think of it
on the spot I want to get it bomb I'll
go get it
popping this blessing o ZZ Shalom I'm
off here and these are titles of two
years ago 21 yeah I get my first had to
to like to soup eight years ago to my
first I got my name right here Oh GZ and
I hurt I says definitely don't hurt at
all
it's like a you just gone for huh I was
like yet good the pace I'm like Nick
they don't [ __ ] hurt at all this one
like kind of hurt a little bit
I feel like anywhere is like tender area
than it hurts you know I mean I thought
that Nick was gonna hurt you neither saw
her to the neck hurt it both fingers
fingers kind of heard that she's burnt
right and watch yeah my head was burning
I stayed burning up
yes it was weird was dollar sign an
hourglass time is money
fill me this one it looks like a nice
kind of building knuckle that across any
sign I'm at the umbrella with the water
jobs a BJP and Aki science you know I
mean we be living a crazy lifestyle
don't get stomach fat cells let's see
what he doesn't pay I got a big ass down
on my stomach but I won't tell ya if
y'all want to go see it they'll see the
fashion video I was getting it in a
fashion because my other stomach
actually heard like a [ __ ] not really
but I was getting a tattoo and I was
like [ __ ] it's a big-ass hat too long
yeah it was like three four hours and I
was I found like the left you like
another three I was like I'm cool
straight like that hmm
my favorite ones with son named Ray I
like the finish on my son's name right
here I'm a big mamma name I got three
dots right here I got the UH the the
bots Mario's logo for LTX I got my I got
my honey and I got a smile now cry later
guys have any favorite stories behind
any of your guts my three does I think
there's like 20 of list I got at the
same time something like that
yeah pretty funny for me I'll be pretty
pretty high there was one time we had a
studio session I think how many been
dead yeah I think no jumper I came in
and everyone was the entire inside the
study of he was doing with all types of
[ __ ] right here I got a double cup say
LTX on it we were selling this on our
first tour how many aqua came up with
this little bowl of designs right here
graffiti was like a la culture diamonds
like la thing you grow up to LA
everybody doing it this is for a dick
it's cool same area I did not
how many times with other how many think
they're yeah Purcell SL and em for short
on mafia Phoenix the cat not be that's
the cat got a Gucci bag gonna let me got
a big ass back with you clapping on
faded I like the Rolling Stones had to
you know I mean if the rock star
lifestyle living like some rock stars
initial boat you family a certain Corp
rights I'm from the Oh singing on a mean
it had a wave voice and I'm my fear and
oh yeah a lot sounds now you I'm gonna
get a retouch because you're the dude
bitter kind of like but it says Orion
right here across right here Cuban
blessings coming here
the shell done more coming though I'm
about to get like a chess piece no
Hollywood time it's gonna say Holly wave
we came up out of Hollywood so [ __ ] you
did anywhere around I like to see the
Hollywood sign people me it's gonna have
how do a sign
ghetto bird flying around they'll cross
streets we'll remember we started making
out of music huh little memoir piece you
found me
I'd be all the glasses not to the years
and so no I don't think I'd ever regret
huh not on me you have to be pretty
stupid Oh get something on your body
that you're gonna trick
[Music]